not
working okay well uh next speaker is y
chy from also from I um she's going to
talk about uh NLP and uh
semantics okay so um why grounded
language and knowledge um I think it's
partly because it's cool but also
because it's going to be an important
step toward Intelligent Communication
so um what do I mean by that I'm going
to characterize that as the ability to
read between the lines which seems to be
um the fundamental difference between
how we understand language as a human
and how machines tend to understand
human language so um given a news
headline like a cheeseburger stepping
for example what does this mean um
someone Steed a cheeseburger or a
cheeseburger stepped someone or a
cheeseburger stepped another
cheeseburger um someone stepped someone
else with a cheeseburger and so forth
and more posible interpretation would be
that someone stepped someone else over a
cheeseburger so uh reading between the
lines require understanding what's in a
sentence as well as things that are not
in the sentence um and so here the fact
that there's probably someone and then
someone else in the scene um has not
been mentioned but we somehow um can
infer this just uh based on the kind of
background knowledge that we have about
the world and similarly when we follow
cooking recipe like this um we see a
sentence like bake for half hour and we
don't even notice that um bake what or
bake where um are not even mentioned and
uh because we almost in instantaneously
F in this sort of missing information um
using the knowledge about the world so
speaking of knowledge according to
philosophers of knowledge there are
different types of knowledge
propositional knowledge is knowledge of
that and um so for example who is the
president of which country and in Bon
what year Etc um but the other kinds of
propositional knowledge are more like
Common Sense type knowledge so bananas
are typically yellow elephants are
bigger than butterflies and so forth and
yet another type of knowledge is
procedural knowledge so this is
knowledge of a how for example how to
bake blueberry muffins or write biso and
compared to um encyclopedic knowledge
which has been studied a lot in NLP um
field uh under this information
extraction effort um relatively less
effort have been made for um learning
the other types of knowledge so the big
question here is then um can we somehow
learn this sort of Common Sense type
knowledge um in uh in the form of some
sort of representation learning and I
expect that um probably the reaction to
this question can be fairly divisive
depending on um where you're coming from
um some of you may be a little bit um
skeptical about this which is
understandable considering what happened
in 70s and 80s in AI but I'm going to
take the other perspective where well uh
life is a short and there's only one way
to find out so I've been um just pocking
around a little bit to find answers for
what kind of knowledge may be learnable
and not learnable what kind of a
representation makes sense and what kind
of uh learning Paradigm might make sense
so just briefly about end to end
learning so um especially for NLP some
sort of like sequence to sequence style
architecture this has been um incredibly
useful for a variety of different task
and that's been really very exciting and
the general recurring them is that
machine Lear the representation tends to
be better than human engineered features
although um I still see that some people
uh integrate both of them anyhow but um
so it's very exciting um the caveat is
that it tends to be successful when
someone can bother to create very large
amount of high quality data um and also
what it means is that we cannot really
do this for all kinds of task so I
worked on neural Sonet composition and
turns out the mankind overall didn't
write enough number of a sonets uh in
entire entire human history so um it's
not enough to feed the data hungry
neural networks um uh to frame it as end
to end learning so we did make use of
language models based on neural network
however it's not end to end so but the
bigger question for us at the moment is
how does this sort of um learning
Paradigm relate to the kind the
different kinds of Common Sense
knowledge so uh part of my research has
been around the procedural language and
knowledge uh these are basically I'm
referring to natural language
instructions and my wishful thought is
that one day in my lifetime I wake up in
the morning there's a robot in my house
um cooking something for me and so
natural Lang uh natural language
instructions are grounded by Nature uh
in the sense uh if you follow that
instruction you are automatically
interacting with the world and changing
the state of the world
so um examples include of course cooking
recipes but also biology wet lab
instructions and more broadly all kinds
of how to do X sort of instructions that
are um available in a very large
quantity online today so the unique
challenges in studying procedural
language is that which is very different
from newswire articles that have been
studied a lot more uh first of all if
you download the stateoftheart parsers
so they tend to think that um imperative
sentences are not very common so grease
with butter is noun with another butter
which sounds really greasy and a lot of
the arguments are really common as
mentioned before something El that's
interesting is that um the identities of
entities change over time in such a way
that um for example whisk X add flour
fold the sugar into the wet mixture so
we cannot really apply um traditional
core reference resolution system
and expect that um this refers to
something exactly mentioned somewhere
before because it's now new entity that
was created as a result of executing
some of these previous sentences so at
the very beginning we thought that um
we're going to create some uh parsing
style representation that we named as
action graph and U the gist of it goes
to something like this so when we have a
sentence like in a large book stir
together milk egg and oil we want to
understand that um stir is the main
action applied to different arguments
like here and for any of this argument
we want to know where they originally
came from so milk may have been um so
these are all arguments of the verb but
um for some of these arguments we want
to know where they came from so they may
have been um ingredents available in
your kitchen but something interesting
happens when we see the next desc so add
a flow to the wet mixture in this case
flow and wet mixture are two different
arguments and so this one refers to the
result of the previous action stir and
so that's our representation like for
every single argument we want to know
exactly where they came from and
something else um to think about is
often times you see a sentence like just
add flower without the second argument
and even in those cases we want want to
know that in fact there's a second
argument which does refer to um one of
the previous previous actions that has
been um executed so the graph structure
just uh briefly look something like this
and um at a high level this is similar
to semantic Ro labeling in natural
language research uh key difference is
that we do want to uh think about
labeling implicit arguments as well and
also um we touch on this notion of um so
this graph represent how different
entities are flowing through a sequence
of different actions which touches on
this question of reference resolution in
a different way and um lastly it's going
to be document level understanding so
unlike sentence level parsing which has
been studied more often um here we want
to be able to do this parsing at a
document level so I'm not going to go
too much um into detail of what kind of
model we were doing it's just a brief y
unsupervised approach based on
probabilistic model where we have a
chicken and egg problem that in order to
do the action graph parsing well we need
to have some sort of a background
knowledge in order to acquire that
knowledge uh we do need to have this
parsing result so not surprisingly uh we
did expectation maximization on it the
reason why we didn't do fully supervised
approaches because The annotation turns
out to be really really um difficult so
we can't really do this in a large
quantity um anyway so the probability
model has some components in it that
does incode uh some notion of knowledge
for example when you see oil and vinegar
mentioned uh in the previous sentences U
it's more likely that you're going to
see dressing as opposed to better and
flour tends to be referenced to some
initial ingredients where whereas better
tends to refer to some sort of
intermediate entity and when you see
actions like um bake the location is
likely to be rather oven than
stove so this sort of knowledge has been
just um uh recovered from unstructured
the text we didn't give this as prior
knowledge yes yeah so I was going to ask
about the middle one so the first first
and the third I see it's starting like w
or something but how do you the middle
one so yeah I I um sort of skipped the
details but um these are part of the
large joint probability model that we
write and some of these are sort of like
um machine translation type like IBM
model one where we learn the translation
of uh words uh when when they appear in
one sentence and then when they maybe
getting mentioned in some other sentence
um so that's roughly what it looks
like uh I approach is does does it scale
I mean because these things may be like
far apart 20 words 30 words apart right
so so um we okay it's then I have to say
something a little bit more so um the
model has two components so one part is
about um this sort of like word to word
mapping the other part has something to
do with graph connectivity because we
somehow need to infer this graph
connectivity as well and so uh when we
do em in uh one part we do uh this graph
structure induction
once we have that we fix it like um so
this is hard em and then we try to infer
the probability score assuming that the
graph structure is correct and so we
repeat until
convergence I yeah sorry um this part I
U meant to go very briefly many because
it sort of sets up the um intuition
toward other work that I was going to
talk more um later so so this one is
this table shows some example knowledge
that's um automatically recovered so for
example when eggs appear first they tend
to so um we tend to see other wording
like egg yolk mixture noodles whites
later and the model learns that um the
EGS are likely to be part of these sort
of composite nouns that appear later so
and by the way I didn't cherry pick
these are just um the order of words in
their increasing probability score um
and then there are other types of
knowledge learned but in general um the
reason why we were doing this in the
first place was because we wanted to be
able to translate unstructured text into
more structured information from which
um abstract away some details and learn
the
prototypical uh structure of um uh how
to knowledge and from which perhaps we
could do planning and then be able to
generate a new recipe so imagine that a
robot in your kitchen uh just look at
what kind of ingredients are valuable
that day and just come up with some nice
recipes so that's what we thought
originally that we might do but after
struggling for a while uh we decided
that it's not going to go anywhere
because action graphs um automatically
learn tend to be very noisy and also
it's not trivial to think about how to
abstract things away so this Le to the
next um approach that was based on um
neural network Bas um basically so the
task definition is that the input is
going to be a title and the list of
ingredients in your kitchen which later
we're going to also generalize for other
types of um generation task like
dialogue response
generation and the output is going to be
just long text with many sentences and
the goal is uh to create a dish that um
satisfies this original goal given as a
title and then try to make use of and
only those ingredients that are given to
us and so initially we thought that well
incode decoder seems super promising so
why don't we try that and see what
happens so this is what
happens uh the title is sausage
sandwiches and RNN starts generating
lots of sandwiches eventually it
recovers a from Sandwich overdose but
still um it repeats things at least wise
so it doesn't really have a very good uh
control over the entire structure Global
coherence tends to be missing and uh one
important difference between the cases
when um this sort of incoda decoda
architecture works and the case like us
uh in in this case when it doesn't work
importantly the alignment ratio is only
minority case so of those words in the
output only 6 to 10% of them align back
to Something in the input which means
that like 90 to 94% of the times it's
really good idea not to pay attention to
the input at all so and somehow a lot of
wor in the output has to be generated
out of nowhere um so in order to handle
that challenge we um we came up with
this um neural checklist model uh very
but just to give you the high level
insights of how this works so the title
is garlic tomato salt
and then maybe there are four different
ingredients as a shown here and we're
going to build upon regular RNN what I
mean by that is really Jus in this case
so um first somehow encode the title and
then there's going to be this checklist
of ingredients that we're going to be
also encoding as some sort of vector
representation and given that we're
going to be projecting one word at a
time and just before that we're going to
have this hidden state um switcher or
classifier that contextually determines
whether I am about to generate a word
that's um non ingredient or uh mention
of new ingredients or co- reference to
something that I have already produced
in the past so it goes something like
this first um let's say we already
generated chop the so at this point um
neural network is going to contextually
decide that H I'm going to generate a
new ingredient in which case it's going
to attend to the list of things that we
haven't used yet and sof to Max over it
and perhaps choose tomatoes and check
that off from the list um and then move
forward so in this work U there's no
sentence boundaries per se but it's just
that uh neuron Network learns to put
where uh period from time to time so
that it's
um makes better sense for us to read so
the second sentence may be di the and at
this point again neural network may
decide contextually that I'm going to
use yet another unused ingredients so of
these three that have not been used it
uh projects and U maybe onion came out
as the most promising Choice check this
off and then move forward so now
something interesting happens when we
want to say add to BL so in this case
it's contextually you usually um add to
something that you have already created
so um of those two ingredients that we
have already used we're going to now um
soft to Max over it and perhaps we chose
uh tomatoes and so that's how it works
so this is high level idea but of course
everything has to be differentiable n to
end and so forth so the checklist is not
really black and white checklist um it's
more like probabilistic checklist so
everything is uh probabilistic and in
addition to that this switcher is also
not really discrete it's more of
interpolation between three different
cases and so that's how it works and of
these three cases only one of them is a
generic language model the other two
cases are based on attention mechanisms
so um one attention it's like a paired
mechanism so one attention is going to
be over available ingredients in a
probabilistic sense and then the other
one is going to be about attention over
used ingredients and so attention Vector
get accumulated over time so we know
probabilistically which ingredients we
have used more so question yeah this is
a generative model so there's attention
in a generative model yeah and how is
that attention moving then so oh I see
some problemistic processes yeah so
everything is probabilistic in this
sense the checklist is basically just a
accumulation of tension over time and
then whenever we want to focus on uh the
used dep portion we just do one minus
those values so that it's attending on
the the other part this the other set of
ingredients in a probabilistic
sense so everything is in the end just
uh Matrix operation Vector operations
plus minus multiplications so once we
have um so the attention part is that um
we have this ingredient list for which
we have original word embedding and then
compared to the hidden state of Gru and
um we did just the usual business of
Computing these attention coefficients
and then um use that coefficient in
order to compose the representation of
the new um ingredient which can
sometimes be combination of like
tomatoes and carrots in which case
ideally when we generate a word out of
it we don't want to say tomato or carrot
but we should say vegetables so that's
uh the high level idea of the model and
so I'm going to just um gloss over some
of this automatic evaluation that's in
the paper but let's look at um example
pairs to see um how you can t aart which
is which so one is human the other one
is machine the title is uh oven eggplant
and the first one goes like this in a
small bowl combine the cheese eggplant
basil oregano tomato sauce and onion mix
well shed mixture into six parties each
about 3/4 inch thick place on baking
bake at 350 degrees for 30 minutes
or until lightly brown Southern Living
magazine sometime in 1980 typed for you
by Nancy Corman the second recipe is
like cook eggplant in boiling water
covered for 10 minutes drain and cut in
half lengthwise scoop out inside living
half inch shell mesh ins size with
Carriage cheese onion bay leaf basil
oregano and tomato sauce a preheat oven
to 350 stuffed eggplant hes place in CER
dish and bake covered for 15 minutes so
let's take a vote um how many like uh
who think this the first one is written
by
Machine one is is it like lack of
opinion or you really think that the
second one is by motion who thinks
second one is by
motion really um no the first one is by
machine um so why did you think the
second one is by
machine no but also just the Style Style
like like sometimes doesn't capitalize I
I see that that's your point yeah so
wouldn't make those errors yeah the
because of this argum sampling nature of
um the way we generate it tends to
really focus on safe language the Adin
language tends to at least in this
particular application adenan was
surprisingly good at generating
grammatically corrected sentence I think
it's because sentences in this domain
tends to be pretty simple there's no uh
really difficult long dependency um
which is more common with newswire text
um so that's partly why uh this was in
the data set which is why arnn sometimes
learn to put that
in uh yeah all comes from data and this
one is more complex in a way so the
procedure that's more complex tends to
not work well with um lstms just yet
question where is that example from this
doesn't seem like a published Source oh
so this is from uh now you're cooking
data set that we uh collected and then
um used and the network was trained on
about
84,000 recipes and uh I mean I I admit
that I chose one that's kind of tricky
and uh chose a recipe generated by
machine that looks better but I can show
you worse examples you could offer a
taste
test yeah um yeah I people keep asking
if I cook that any of this the answer is
no I that's why I I wish the robot does
it for me um so skillet chicken rice um
in this case uh it's relatively easy
case in the sense this recipe exists a
lot in of Veri of different forms
Baseline is RNN so it starts okay like
in know larg Skillet Brown Chicken in
oil add chicken and rice cook but it
starts repeating unsurprisingly at rice
and broth Stern more rice keep cooking
um adding more rice and I wonder what it
becomes in the end if you cook it this
way so checkl on the other hand is able
to um have much cleaner Global coherence
so um it doesn't repeat as much which is
a little bit surprising in a way because
we are not really U modeling the local
or Global coherence in a very precise
way we are just sketching out the
architecture so that it does have some
access to the Global um outline of the
generation and somehow that seems to
really help for it to generate um texted
that's much better so but this one is
easier example and by by the way this is
human recipe that's um generally more
complex and um there's just more detail
so this is harder example chocolate
covered the potato chips I don't know
how many of you had this in your life
before Baseline doesn't know what to do
with it because it just hasn't seen this
example before so probably it's a good
idea to preheat the OV but start um
baking an empty
pen but it's checklist to does something
a little bit more sensible although now
it's starts making some mistakes too
because it's dealing with context that's
not as familiar so it uh also does weird
thing at the beginning I mean it does
some baking suddenly and then uh think
uh start to m melting chocolate probably
it's a good idea um there's a bit of
this Gramma errors here eventually it
does fry in hot oil which Mak sense and
then serve hot except that um I wonder
what happens if you try to fry something
that's already covered in
chocolate uh human recipe in this case
it's very very detailed so this is a
hard example and I'm going to talk a
little bit more about the limitations of
uh checklist model but just briefly we
also applied the same system for
dialogue system Generation Um with based
on the data set from emnlp bested paper
um when it all 2015 and there even
though our model was not really
developed for that task we did um better
anyway so the part that I wanted to
highlight a little bit is the so it
seems that we can go pretty far with
simple sequence to sequence models but
something critical is missing still so
given an example like de fried
cauliflower so this is also a little bit
hard example because people don't def
fry cauliflower very often so this is
what checklist does wash and dry the
cauliflower probably a good idea and
then um hit the oil in a skillet fry the
sauce until they are golden brown
probably reasonable but um what's wrong
the cauliflower is still fresh it has
not been fried ever so um in order to
know this sort of mistakes it seems that
um just surface string based models
probably are not going to go very far
and it seems that we need to have much
better reasoning capability or knowledge
integrated into the model so that goes
to the next component which is in
preparation we don't we didn't really
nail down our name yet so I don't know
what it's going to be called yet but
it's sort of um similar to Chris Dyer
reference aware language model and also
Yan recurrent entity networks in the
sense we want to have entity
representations that are
recurrent um actually let me just do it
this way so first the idea is that um
it's going to be parsing by simulation
where analysis by synthesis um may or
may not make sense uh the right away but
um so the assumption is that we the way
human understand language is that we
already know what kind of things we can
actually act on in the real world so we
have already some knowledge about some
actions that we can perform and we also
have some good understanding about the
causality of these actions so in this
particular case we think about the
location change compostition change um
whether you wash something or not
whether you cook something or not
whether the temperature changes and and
so forth um and then um ideally we want
to have embodied robot that goes out and
learn this sort of action calot
Knowledge from interacting with the
world but since I don't know such robot
is not available to me yet um I thought
that we could just ask a turers about
this sort of knowledge and then start
from there so let's say we already
learned some um predefined set of
actions and first we read in some uh
language sentences in instructions using
Gru and then what happens next is that
um we have this sort of like fixed the
set of actions that are represented as
maybe a vector or matrices and also uh
ingredient list as uh list of um um
vectors and we are going to attend over
this so we attend over actions we attend
over entities and we compose um so we
have now um uh alignment coefficient
sorry attention coefficients and then
once we have that we can compose new
action representation as well as new um
uh new uh entity representation such
that we learn to uh predict what
happened to different entities so that's
a sort of a high level idea but um it's
a work in preparation so uh that's the
part about procedural language now I'm
going to uh touch briefly on other types
of knowledge that I've been also um
toying with so this is going to be by
and large about um knowledge about
objects actions and events and so last
year I had this um view that maybe in
order to
um cope with this reporting biases so
people don't say that elephants are
bigger than butterflies um or um whether
when horse is eating whether whether the
horse is standing or sitting it seems
like we don't have much hope to learn
these sort of things from language so
perhaps we should look at images and
what makes a wedding a wedding like um
usually people uh exchange a V and then
uh uh dancing happens later so we wanted
to learn this sort of knowledge by
combining um images with language and by
and large it tends to work for learning
a small set of knowledge but this year I
thought that um I'm going to to try
something different because um image
processing tends to be very very
expensive still and um the amount of
knowledge that I learn out of it seems
somewhat um um in a smaller scale so
this year uh I'm going back to just
language only version and so that's
going to be uh something like this so
people don't say things like I am larger
than a chair um or than larger than a
pen or stone or or a bowl or a towel so
how do we learn this sort of knowledge
without looking at images at all so
here's an idea although people don't say
those things the way people talk about
the world implies a lot about this sort
of object object knowledge so you I can
throw the pen or stone or chair or bowl
and towel which tends to mean a variety
of different physical relative knowledge
that X probably is bigger than y x
weighs more than y and therefore for
probably after this action Y moves
faster than x so um it covers some of
these preconditions and post to
conditions of actions and we can
represent this as some sort of a frame
knowledge such that for um any pair of
roles involved in an action we can think
about different physical
implications um coming from that verb so
uh if you walk into the house uh
probably you're smaller than the house
lighter than the house house and so
forth and also if you squash the bug
with if I do that with my butt then um
uh number of different things are true
so uh with that in mind um what we do is
basically reverse engineering some of
these some aspects of Common Sense
knowledge by solving two related puzzles
simultaneously so we want to learn verb
physics frame knowledge as well as
inferring object object
relations um in this work we tried um
size weight strength flexibility and
speed and um we do that without
embodiment and importantly some of this
physical knowledge is not even visual so
weight tends to be not visual or we
think it's a visual but um with com
current computer vision um it's not
really visual so strength and
flexibility and even Spirit yeah we can
look at videos but it's hard to process
a lot a lot of videos so the idea is
that by creating this sort of like
inference Network as a vector graph we
can solve this puzzle so very briefly it
looks promising um and so I'm going to
now uh wrap up uh what we learned so far
about representation learning of Common
Sense knowledge so I've been going a
little bit back and forth between the
representation choice so at the
beginning action graph was more symbolic
and then um for the purpose of
generating and composing new recipes it
seems that such a symbolic
representation is not necessary um when
the um Target task is close to knowledge
and um then it seems that we can get
away just with um implicit
representation in the network um and so
um On a related note an learning uh
seems applicable in some cases like um
the neutal checklist model case when the
procedure knowledge tends to align
pretty well with what's in the surface
string and in those cases we can do that
but in the second part of the talk where
we wanted to learn uh knowledge that's
not really mentioned explicitly in text
um especially propositional knowledge
about objects and actions it seems that
setting up an and learning framework
doesn't make as much sense and in fact
we probably want to solve this sort of
questions more directly so that's what
we did and reverse engineering certain
types of Common Sense knowledge seems
feasible and perhaps we can think more
about that and lastly um there are this
questions about like how do we organize
knowledge that um we learn and one
hypothetical thought toward this is that
perhaps a lot of this knowledge is
really tied to lexical knowledge or
frame knowledge so that's one option we
could organize and in fact I was close
ing over the modeling detail but some
part of the model although it's based on
Factor graph the um un factors are based
on uh embeddings learned from skip gram
style model so there's some um
opportunities for better integrating
symbolic and neural representation so
that concludes my
talk questions we
time
y yeah I was interested with the
generative models of the recipe so you
said you didn't you didn't actually
generate one of those symbolic graphs
when you were producing the the generat
Rees right right yeah so I mean I was
kind of interested in that cuz it it
feels like I mean some of those um
inconsistencies yeah it feels like a
recipe is a rather different kind of
thing to be generating than like piece
of art or a piece of music or something
it's somehow like a recipe somehow is
either like valid or not when when
you're actually doing it so I I I guess
I mean does that mean that there might
be some promising actually trying to
generate a graph and then afterwards
generating the language descrition after
that so that's an excellent question in
fact Klo kiden was the leading author
for um the first two pieces of a work um
in her thought is she did do that so she
was generating text together with graph
it's just that it was really time for
her to um graduate so we didn't write a
paper or um yeah we we we didn't follow
up on that but so we did do that and
what we got is that if we TR so in that
case we are training the mo the neural
network to learn from automatically
pared action graphs so that's going to
be noisy um but keep although it's noisy
it seems like it's learning some of
these prominent patterns in a meaningful
way um when we generate text together
with a graph it tends to over specify
things somehow but um these things may
one may be able to address these things
with more investigation but that's sort
of where we wrapped things up at that
point and then currently we're trying to
see whether we can um validate whether
something makes sense or not without um
explicit graph representation so that's
uh the third pie that I was mentioning
briefly where you have this network
architecture that could simulate what's
happening to the entity is in the world
and the way you prove whether you
understood something or not is to be
able to U predict correctly what
happened to each of these entities in
the
end so that's potentially one version of
it I think there may be other ways of
thinking about this in fact I began also
thinking about story understanding like
you know you do things to each other and
change each other each other's feelings
and it's almost like this sort of um
representation where things happen to
entities and then you want to learn what
happened to them and that's how you um
prove that you understood text Beyond
being able to label which is noun which
is verb and and so
forth yes how often also on the
generation thing how often do you think
it is that the model is just
regurgitating whole sentences or longer
things uh copied directly from the
training set yeah so copy doesn't happen
very often when um the generation surf
uh uh SPAC is somewhat constrained by
some means even in a soft way so the
checklist that has this attention over
ingredients tends to prevent um rnn's
from behaving just copying everything
and then repeat but RNN tend to do that
especially when it's more familiar with
the context when context is not familiar
it tends to start generating very
strange sequence of
things yeah so uh uh I'm reminded of the
Poetry we're showing the Sonet so is
that oh there you have so right so is
that like some kind of a similar graph
over emotion yeah so H yeah now that you
asked me that I didn't see that coming
but yeah I happen to have this slide so
I mentioned earlier that end to end sick
to sick model doesn't work with Sonet
generation fortunately Kevin Knight at
isi already had finite State automata
constructed over um 15K vocabulary back
then and so if you sample out of this
finite State automata you get legal
Sonet it's just that it's completely
random doesn't make any sense whatsoever
so we intersected that with um lstms and
um there are a number of engineering
details for example uh it's really hard
to generate out of lstm that happens to
follow the rhyming rules so we generate
things backward and then there are some
other additional details the language
model was trained on song lyrics so that
uh a lot of things are out there as well
as Wikipedia um and so this is um one
example Sonet that was composed by the
machine so the input is just touring
that's the title and it goes like this
creating some electric SL machine of
hearing those familiar voices say awake
behind an empty picture mean the windows
open over Ln K consider me a regular
expression or maybe something thing very
quickly typed and I forget about an old
Obsession a 100 thousands people getting
hyped it knows something he come the
biggest part of my computer and take
another Journey down the road or set a
balance on a minor scooter or even
matter whose Enigma code and music text
control of all the means surrounded by a
world of strange machines
[Applause]
so but I mean for me the the really um
uh Insight so the takeaway message at
least for me was that although n to n
may not be always possible there's
something about the sort of like base
components like language model when it's
combined with um like uh constraints
constrainted optimization like in this
case it's discrete decoding but it seems
that we can do a lot of things and IM
like current hypothesis for me is that
um some of these things that work really
well with incode decoder may work even
better if we had very very strong
language model combined with some other
interesting inference algorithms
yes just to guess is the basic idea of
this intersection to kind of use the r&m
to um score order the possible things
from the state machine yeah okay yeah I
guess I was going to ask did you try
prod of exports kinds of
models no so expert which uh yeah takes
your rhyming and right um there may be
something interesting to
consider uh yeah we no we haven't done
that in fact actually for me the biggest
challenge right now is that it's sort of
on topic but Global coherence is not
there and that seems like really big
Challenge and one hypothetical thought
is that maybe we can do something like
deep style transfer that sham showing
toward the end of his talk where um you
have a coherent story combined that with
some different style of language like
Sonet language um in fact we have that
work going on but um the coherence it's
really hard to
keep even with
that okay we should
we